dev canada has launched a new campaign
throwing shade at bell media over their
controversial firing of long-time anchor
lisa leflem so for those who don't know
canadian tv viewers were shocked when
the long-time ctv national news anchor
was suddenly let go by the network's
parent company bell media after a
successful 35-year run
and shortly after the news broke earlier
this month canadians were desperate for
answers leading lisa to share her own
video on social media revealing she was
blindsided by the management's business
decision
hello everyone
today with a range of emotions i'm
sharing with you some information about
me and my career with ctv news
for 35 years i have had the privilege of
being welcomed into your homes to
deliver the news on a nightly basis so i
felt you should hear this directly from
me
on june 29th i was informed that bell
media made a quote business decision to
end my contract bringing to a sudden
close my long career with ctv news
i was blindsided and am still shocked
and saddened by bell media's decision
i was also asked to keep this
confidential from my colleagues and the
public until the specifics of my exit
could be resolved
that has now happened and and i want you
to know what these last 35 years have
meant to me
everything
now following that video the shock
quickly turned to outrage when several
reports emerged suggesting various
reasons behind her firing one claimed
the decision was made because of lisa
pushing back against ctv news chief
michael melling over her request to
cover more on the war in ukraine another
claimed lisa's firing was in part due to
her decision to stop dying her hair over
the coveted pandemic as salons were
forced to close yeah the globe and mail
quoted a senior ctv official who said
that execs were uncomfortable with
lisa's decision to grow utter hair
naturally michael melling reportedly
brought up lisa's gray hair color when
he saw it
took on a purple hue because of the
studio lighting yeah now in response to
this dove canada is addressing the issue
of ageism and sexism in the workplace by
encouraging women to keep the gray and
embrace getting older
[Music]
so sharing a powerful message alongside
the video dove writes this aging is
beautiful
as we should all be able to do it on our
own terms and without any consequences
that's why
we're going gray and donating 100 000 to
catalyst a canadian nonprofit
organization dedicated to helping build
inclusive workplace for all
women
you know i wonder if
executives were hoping that this would
just go away but when you have unilever
who is the owner of dove
a massive company coming up and saying
oh no
we see this this is not okay it's not
going away anytime soon and then it begs
to me
we're just saying it while this was
playing i was like how many women before
lisa
are probably like yeah that happened to
me too
you know being edged out as they get
older yeah you know it's so i mean it's
it's and it's it must be incredible for
lisa to feel the support that she feels
that's what i was thinking about i mean
you know certain names that ctv have
been trending
for days uh there's a petition that has
over 150 000 signatures to get lisa back
on the air at ctv
lots of opinions going on right now
skippy is saying i hope lisa gets picked
up by a better channel that nourishes
her journalistic pursuits and focuses
less
on her appearance
uh yazzy's saying the lighting issue is
bs if a person can properly light
someone get someone who can
v is saying lisa was treated very badly
she contributed so much to the channel
not fair they let her down visario
saying lisa is a professional terrific
broadcaster she deserved better bbn is
saying this is sad and i'm surprised
this happened in canada i didn't expect
that so you know that's a really good uh
thing that you brought up bean because
you know listen we've heard about this
in hollywood we've heard about how women
when they hit a certain age they're
treated differently they don't get the
same amount of parts
i remember i forget the actress she went
gray at the cannes film festival and it
like
sent
you know the media in a tizzy and
everybody was talking about how this
huge actress died or you know went
natural on a red carpet and i was like
my goodness can we get over this so i
think that when this has not only
happened in canada but lisa leflem who
you know lloyd robertson retired at age
77 i i don't think anyone thought lisa
was going anywhere this is someone who's
won numerous awards 35-year career is so
well respected when i think of lisa and
i'm a woman in the industry on
television like i understand ageism i
understand sexism but uh i just don't
even think about her appearance when i
think of lisa leflam i don't even you're
too busy listening to what she's saying
yeah i thought i don't even think about
that so even i was surprised by this but
to your point we are now hearing more
stories coming out from former employees
from in all respects not just ctv just
everywhere in general about how they
feel like they've been treated
differently hitting a certain age not
just someone who's in front of the
camera but overall yeah well i mean
listen you look at men men are revered
the moment they get distinctly
distinguished the term is they turn into
a silver fox oh yeah right
or or a man gets a wrinkle and he looks
experienced i hear you the language is
different and
and so women are seen differently as we
age it's like
you know we even talk about we were
talking about in the call earlier today
the sweet spot in marketing is 25 to 54
apparently well there's a lot of women
past 54 and men in
spending money so this this whole 25 to
54 never made doesn't make sense to me
anymore i i just think we need to look
at people differently we need to value
people for what they bring to the table
and lisa is a very valuable person and
does an incredible job and it's i i just
feel like what are we missing here like
what are we missing to the story well i
think it is what it is which is so
unfortunate that this has happened i
mean no send off this seemed extremely
cold this seemed like this wasn't like
okay we're you know this is a thank you
for your time here this is a send up
this is just like goodbye the fact that
she even had to announce it on her own
social media that she was blindsided
like this has not gone down down well
and i'm sure we will take it
do you think no no i don't think this
when dove hops on this and to talk about
it right um i think this is a
conversation that needs to happen i
think this is happening a lot
uh people on camera and not on camera uh
i think this is just happening
everywhere and you know it's been
wonderful reading all the stories i
don't know if you've seen these uh with
lisa thumb having such a huge presence
on television in canada how many women
have come forward er saying i've now
gone natural or i i went great because i
saw lisa do it and you know salons were
closed or people are embracing uh their
age it takes a lot of work it takes a
lot of work people and like you know
whoever established those standards like
we're breaking the mold like it's time
like we just want to age gracefully this
is just who we are i don't know who
we're doing this for anymore but then
if this is the reason why she got fired
again i think it comes down to that that
the marketing thing where it says the
sweet spot is 25 to 50 like there's that
thing out there in television that
that's the sweet spot yeah the sweet
spot should be much wider right there
are people living longer doing more
traveling the world experiencing things
life does not stop at 50. i know but if
you have people in positions of
management with archaic
ideas i understand we're making those
decisions and maybe that needs to change
but that's the conversation we need to
be having the world is changing people
are living longer they're living better
lives they want to relate to people who
are at the stage of life that they're in
not just one like just because you're a
certain age you can you know you can
relate to someone who's older or to
someone who's younger you don't just
have to relate to a person who's exactly
your age that doesn't make sense
anyway we have lots of feelings so much
to say like so much i'm getting fired up
so are all the comments i really
appreciate all the comments ideas saying
who reveres men for wrinkles and gray
hair
uh me and my mid-20s friends sure don't
uh
church of jesus is saying the hollywood
loophole
shad spike is saying i'm absolutely
appalled with ctv and bell media they
lost a viewer if not thousands now from
their national news broadcast i have
been reading that time and time again
the reason why i don't think this is
going anywhere is because this has put
such a bad taste in people's mouths
they don't even want to watch this
newscast anymore i've been seeing that a
lot and and i'm seeing that a lot on
here as well you know i hope that you
know businesses and networks and
everyone across the board takes this in
canada and really i mean sure it'd be
nice in the states as well but right now
we're talking about canada really takes
a look at this and like as an
opportunity to be better and to do
better and to me make people feel more
included i hope that happens i do too i
know